all right you're done there were a lot
of new things that time but after all
you're becoming a seasoned Android
programmer by now as I mentioned before
we're going to use notificationcompat
builder to build our notification it's
easy to build a nice-looking
notification that has our icon
representing the weather forecast the
title of our app and our content text
the forecast with highs and lows we're
going to use another class from the
support library to create a task stack
builder for our pending intent this is a
simple case of task stack builder
because all we have is a single item on
our stack we just add the next intent
and use it to build our pending intent
that we pass into the notification
manager finally we call the notification
manager with the built intent from our
builder with the notify function one of
the great things about notification
manager is it can be used from any
thread even though it is displaying UI